J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez, vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour, vous le savez, dans Septante Minutes Avec, j'aime explorer avec mes invités des sujets de fond pour mieux comprendre le monde qui nous entoure, mieux comprendre comment notre société fonctionne.
Et du coup, c'est logique et c'est très naturel pour moi d'inviter des chercheurs en psychologie sociale. On a déjà pu parler à de nombreuses reprises de la montée des extrêmes, de l'impact des réseaux sociaux sur nos démocraties.
Aujourd'hui, avec mon invité Jasper Van Assche, on explore les notions de polarisation, de multiculturalité, de contacts intergroupes et enfin de cynisme politique.
Ça fait beaucoup de choses, mais vous allez voir que tout ça est lié, tout ça est très fluide. Et une fois qu'on a compris, ça coule de source, en fait.
On parle pas mal de Bruxelles spécifiquement, vous allez voir, mais c'est parce que c'est une ville très cosmopolite, justement.
Et on a pu y observer un vote que je vais qualifier de cynique, aux dernières élections. Vous allez voir ce que j'entends par là.
Mais donc, si vous n'habitez pas à Bruxelles, rassurez-vous, c'est juste en guise d'exemple pour voir en quoi toutes ces mécaniques sociales, voilà, sur quoi ça peut déboucher.
Ah, et dernière chose : je tente cette saison de mettre aussi les épisodes sur YouTube, intégralement en vidéo.
Voilà, ça prend du temps, mais comme je vous racontais cet été, j'ai créé quelques outils pour accélérer tout ça.
Donc, si vous voulez nous voir en 4K HDR super méga haute définition, et je comprends parce que nous sommes très beaux, allez, vous abonner à Septante Minutes Avec sur YouTube, le lien est en description.
Bonne écoute. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Jasper Van Assche. Bonjour.
Bonjour, enchanté.
Jasper Van Assche, tu es post-doc à la FWO ici en Flandre. Tu es act-- C'est ton dernier mois à Gand, tu me disais.
On est ici à l'Université libre de Bruxelles. Tu es chargé de cours au CESCoP, donc le centre de-- lié à la psychologie sociale.
J'oublie toujours à quoi correspondent les lettres, c'est un petit peu long.
Et tu donnes cours, voilà, ici à la faculté de psychologie, notamment, voilà, en ce qui concerne la psychologie sociale, puisque c'est ta spécialité.
Ouais.
C'est ça.
Tout à fait.
Et tu te concentres surtout sur les enjeux, on va dire, liés au politique.
Mmh-mmh.
Les notions de radicalisation, les notions de polarisation, de relations intergroupes et tout ça. C'est de ça dont on va parler aujourd'hui.
Donc, déjà, merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation.
Avec plaisir.
Donc voilà, je disais, donc, tu es chargé de cours ici à l'ULB. Comment est-ce que tu es arrivé dans ton parcours académique à t'intéresser à la politique ?
C'est une bonne question. J'avais... Pendant mon doctorat, j'étais, disons, influencé par plusieurs chercheurs et chercheuses, académiques, mais aussi non académiques.
Et j'ai eu beaucoup de liberté dans l'équipe de Gand pour vraiment élaborer sur la question politique qui m'intéresse.
Et là, c'est aussi une question un petit peu des profs là-bas, Alain Van Hiele et Arne Roets.
Mh.
Ils sont très très forts en psychologie politique et on n'a pas beaucoup de centres qui focalisent ces thèmes-là en Belgique et même en Europe.
Tu es tombé sur des professeurs qui aimaient beaucoup. Je connaissais pas cette notion de psychologie politique. Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire exactement ?
Bah, c'est, on est entre les sciences po et les sciences psychologiques.
Ouais, uh uh.
Et donc, ce qu'on va faire, on utilise nos théories, nos cadres théoriques de la psychologie et de la psychologie sociale, notamment, pour les appliquer au niveau de la politique.
Et donc, il y a plusieurs domaines de recherche là-dedans, mais souvent, on regarde les attitudes politiques parmi l'électorat, mais aussi les discours politiques parmi les politiciens, politiciennes.
Et on essaye de comprendre le où et le comment et le pourquoi de tout ce qui se passe au niveau politique.
Mh. Et donc,
donc, psychologie politique. Toi, tu fais la psychologie sociale. Est-ce que la psychologie politique, c'est obligatoirement la psychologie sociale ou bien est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui font
des thérapies avec des politiciens et qui...
Ah oui. Non. Il y a plusieurs études qui, par exemple, font des analyses des discours des politiciens qui-
Ouais, linguistiques alors plutôt.
Oui, qui n'utilisent pas vraiment des cadres théoriques de la psychologie sociale, mais la plupart, donc, chaque année, je fais une conférence, un colloque de psychologie sociale international.
Et là, on se trouve un peu au milieu parce qu'il y a beaucoup de psychologues, mais il y a aussi beaucoup de politologues.
Et donc, on parle souvent des mêmes thèmes en utilisant d'autres théories, par exemple. Mais, disons que pour moi, la psychologie sociale se
focalise sur l'influence des autres, sur nos comportements, nos pensées, nos attitudes, etc.
Et donc, au niveau politique, on est souvent influencé, donc, de-
Mh.
Bah, par d'autres personnes.
Oui, par notre environnement, tout ça.
Ouais.
Et donc voilà, tu disais : tu as croisé sur ton chemin des professeurs qui s'intéressaient beaucoup à la psychologie politique.
Uh huh.
Est-ce que c'est seulement ça ou bien est-ce que c'est aussi le contexte politique ici en Belgique où tu t'es dit : « Y a-- ça m'intéresse, ça me, ça m'anime, ça me-
Ouais.
Ça me, c'est, c'est une force motrice, ça m'intéresse beaucoup. »
Oui, oui.
Oui ?
Je pense que... Ben, en général, dans les médias, on se focalise surtout sur ce qui se passe aux États-Unis, mais notre contexte ici en Belgique est beaucoup plus riche, je trouve.
On a plus que deux partis ou plus que deux options. Et cette nuance qu'on peut ajouter dans notre contexte ici, ça me passionne vraiment.
Et ça me motive aussi de plonger là-dedans. On a beaucoup de partis colorés, de l'extrême droite jusqu'à l'extrême gauche.
On a, ben, les, disons, les débats ou les tensions linguistiques aussi. Et donc on a-- y a plusieurs choses à faire ici.
Et donc, oui, ça, c'était une de mes motivations aussi.
Mh. Oui, oui. Oui, donc plus de nuances, plus de nuances de gris dans-
Mh.
Les couleurs que, par exemple, effectivement, tu disais aux États-Unis où ils ont deux options.
Ouais.
Donc voilà, parmi les sujets que tu as très fort recherchés, y a la question de ce qu'on appelle la polarisation.
Mh.
Donc c'est un mot qui revient souvent quand on parle de politique dans l'époque actuelle.
On parle beaucoup de silos idéologiques, de-
Ouais.
De bulles idéologiques, etc. Alors, je vais poser la question simplement pour commencer : est-ce qu'on vit dans une société polarisée ?
C'est une question très très intéressante dont, ben, on n'a pas de réponse facile.
Ça, c'est souvent les chercheurs, c'est...
Oui.
Je pose une question simple et puis en fait-
Non.
Douze questions.
Donc si la question est : « Est-ce que la société de maintenant-
Ouais.
Est polarégée, polarisée », pardon, je dirais oui, plutôt oui.
Plus qu'avant ?
Ça, c'est une autre question-
OK.
Que même empiriquement, on n'en est pas sûr, parce que c'est vraiment comme tu dis un buzzword.
Mh.
Et je viens de parler des différences entre des domaines qui nourrissent la psychologie politique. Et même, par exemple, souvent, les politologues ont une définition un peu plus différente que
nous en ce qui concerne la polarisation.
Et moi, je dirais que oui, y a tendance, que y a plus de polarisation, plus d'opinions qui vont dans les extrêmes.
Et on a plusieurs études qui montrent que ça peut être lié à d'autres choses plutôt contextuelles ou plutôt historiques qui ont-
Mh.
Un peu bougé nos attitudes. Mais donc peut-être, y a encore beaucoup de personnes au milieu-
Qui n'ont pas d'opinions extrêmes, qui ne se trouvent pas, ben, tricher-- pas tricher, c'est un grand mot, mais qui ont encore beaucoup de confiance dans nos institutions politiques, etc., etc.
Ouais, ouais.
Mais donc y a, ben, y a beaucoup de-
De nuances.
Bougements dans la société.
Ouais.
Oui.
OK, on va-- Mais on va parler aussi, hein, des personnes qui sont un petit peu, pas très politisées, pas très radicalisées, un peu au milieu, qui s'intéressent pas vraiment à tout ça.
Mais donc, tu parlais des politologues en disant : « On n'a pas forcément la même définition », mais du coup, je vais poser la question.
C'est quoi en fait la polarisation pour toi en tant que, voilà, psychologue social ?
Ouais. Pour moi, c'est quelque chose qui se passe au niveau d'un groupe ou d'un-
Mh.
D'une société, par exemple. Et ça veut dire que y a plus de réponses extrêmes, quoi qu'on parle de
support pour des partis extrêmes ou non, ou si on parle d'attitudes en général, attitudes envers la politique, attitudes envers des personnes qui ne sont pas comme nous, par exemple.
Et donc, là, on voit quand même une croissance de plus d'opinions polarisées. Y a aussi un autre cadre qui est plutôt, qui regarde plutôt l'individu.
Et là, la polarisation, ce qu'on appelle la polarisation affective, c'est plutôt que nous, dans nos têtes ou dans nos pensées, nos attitudes, on fait une différence entre
ceux et celles qui sont dans notre groupe et l'autre groupe-
Mh.
Ou des membres d'un autre groupe. Et on peut regarder n'importe quel groupe social, mais par exemple, aux États-Unis, quand on parle de polarisation, c'est plutôt toi, par exemple, qui trouves que parti A
est beaucoup plus compétent et chaleureux et n'importe quoi que parti B.
Pour moi, c'est plutôt quelque chose qui se passe entre les individus, mais donc pour beaucoup d'autres personnes, ça peut s-- on peut être polarisé dans notre propre système, dans notre propre soi.
Et pour moi, j'utilise plutôt le favoritisme de l'autre groupe comme terme pour vraiment utiliser pour décrire ce qui se passe dans nous.
Donc, on favorise notre propre groupe et on trouve que notre propre groupe est le meilleur et beaucoup plus, ben, compétent, chaleureux, etc.
C'est un point de vue de psychologue social, finalement. C'est la-- voilà, c'est ça.
Oui.
Mais donc, donc il faut-- donc on comprend alors ce terme de polarisation comme, on est de moins en moins au centre, pour dire ça comme ça, et on est de plus en plus avec des opinions...
C'est quoi le mot que je vais employer ? Droite forte ou gauche forte et moins un truc au milieu un peu tiède-
Oui.
Qui parle à tout le monde.
C'est-- voilà. Et donc, OK. Là, c'est marrant parce qu'avant de préparer cet épisode, pour moi, polarisation, ça voulait dire autre chose, mais ça, c'est visiblement, j'avais complètement tort.
Ouais.
Pour moi, ça voulait dire-
Si je-- Ah oui, oui.
Pour moi, ça voulait dire que on avait une grande-- une segmentisation de la société
et que on avait plusieurs groupes qui se formaient et qu'on regardait tous l'autre groupe en se disant : « Mais ils sont complètement fous.
» « On n'arrive même plus à leur parler. » « On ne comprend pas comment ils peuvent dire ça. » Et on est de plus en plus f-- une société fracturée, divisée.
Et c'est comme ça que je l'avais compris, mais en fait, non, c'est pas comme ça que tu définis-
Ça peut être un résultat, bien sûr. Et je voulais demander si je peux aussi poser des questions.
Oui oui, bien sûr, bien sûr.
Ça m'intéresse très fort quand tu dis que tu avais une autre idée. Et donc, quand je parle de mes recherches avec mes amis, par exemple, tout le monde a sa propre définition
de, par exemple, le mot polarisation, mais aussi d'autres mots que j'utilise beaucoup.
Et ça, c'est aussi très intéressant de regarder là-dedans et de voir comment les définitions se touchent.
Parce que pour moi, je pense que cette fragmentinasi-- fragmentalisation de la société, ça peut être un résultat des attitudes plus polarisées.
D'accord, d'accord.
Oui. Et surtout, la négativité et l'hostilité envers l'autre groupe ou des autres groupes, ça peut être un résultat de ce qui se passe au niveau de la polarisation.
Oui, oui. Ok, ok. Et donc, on va parler alors de cette négativité, ce cynisme, et donc tu dis que c'est le résultat de la polarisation.
Qu'est-ce qui cause tout ça ? Qu'est-ce qui fait que tout ça arrive ? Et je posais la question tout à l'heure, est-ce que ça arrive plus qu'avant ?
Oui.
Je pense, le moteur principal de la polarisation, et c'est ça que j'ai, par exemple, avec mon collègue Olivier Klein et avec des personnes du gang,
on en a écrit un peu, on a fait quelques études aussi au niveau de la politique Belgique.
Et le moteur principal, c'est ce sentiment de cynisme. Et ce cynisme, c'est pas que la méfiance envers la politique ou envers les politiciens et politiciennes.
C'est vraiment, y a cette dimension de, disons, de méfiance, de-- euh pardon, de colère, je veux dire, et vraiment un dégoût de ce qui se passe au niveau de la politique.
Et donc là, il y a des études plutôt sociologiques qui montrent que c'est vrai qu'il y a moins de confiance en politique qu'avant.
Par exemple, je pense qu'Ipsos le fait aux États-Unis chaque année et dans les années 60, c'était presque 70 % des personnes qui ont confiance dans le gouvernement.
Maintenant, ça a tombé. Je pense qu'on est à moins de 30 %. Aussi, quand on regarde d'autres
dimensions ou d'autres indicateurs,
il y avait cette-- j'ai oublié la source maintenant, mais il y a cette
organisation de sondage qui aussi chaque année demande quel est le, disons, la formation ou la profession la moins, la moins digne ou,
où tu fais la moins de confiance.
C'était à nouveau, à l'époque, c'était les vendeurs de voitures.
Oui, d'occasion.
Et maintenant, ce sont les politiciens et politiciennes.
Oui, oui. Ok, ok.
Et donc tout cela, ça n'arrive pas dans la vie. Il y a toujours d'autres influences, au niveau socioculturel, qui ont changé et qui peuvent aussi déterminer un peu ce cynisme.
Mais donc ce cynisme-là, ça, c'est selon moi ou selon nous, le moteur de ce qu'on voit dans la société, des opinions plus extrêmes, pardon, des votes plus extrêmes, ben le succès électoral de
certains partis, etc., etc.
Ok, donc les gens, de manière générale, sont déçus, n'ont pas confiance et donc se disent : « Bon, il faut un changement fort, il faut pas quelque chose de tiède, de mou, il faut vraiment un changement radical. »
Oui.
Et ça peut être à gauche, à droite.
Est-ce que ça--
'fin, alors, on parle aussi en sciences politiques d'extrême centrisme. Est-ce qu'on peut être, voilà, polarisé comme étant fortement, fortement au centre en se disant : « Je veux quelque chose de... »
Oui.
En théorie, c'est possible, mais je pense que,
surtout en Belgique, par exemple, le populisme, le cynisme, etc., est souvent lié avec des partis ou des politiciens qui sont en dehors du système et qui sont anti-établissement.
Oui.
Mais c'est tout à fait possible qu'il y a
un mouvement politique qui se définisse dans le centre, mais qui dit : « On va changer des choses, on va faire autrement que dans l'époque où ce que le gouvernement
aujourd'hui fait, on n'est pas d'accord, on va changer, mais en restant politiquement au centre.
» Même si là, il y a beaucoup de définitions différentes aussi. Il y a des-- moi, par exemple, je pense que cette unidimensionnalité de gauche vers droite, c'est un peu, ben, on va un peu trop rapide là-dedans.
Et je pense qu'il y a beaucoup plus de nuances et beaucoup plus de dimensions aussi qui-- on peut être, par exemple, plutôt à gauche au niveau socioculturel, mais au niveau économique, on peut être plutôt à droite, etc.
Il y a des exemples.
Ouais.
Et donc voilà, mais on va continuer là-dedans. Mais donc, tu évoquais donc ce sentiment de méfiance, donc le contraire de la confiance.
On est très très fort déçu. On se dit que ça ne fonctionne pas comme ça. Et donc une volonté importante de changement et donc polarisation.
Qu'est-ce qui-- est-ce que tu t'es intéressé aussi à la question de : mais pourquoi est-ce que les gens sont déçus ?
D'où est-ce qu'il vient ce manque de confiance ?
Ah oui, c'est une bonne question. Dans mes recherches, jusqu'à maintenant, j'ai pas encore fait des études qui regardent le cynisme, par exemple, comme résultat d'autre chose.
Sans doute, il y a des aspects de personnalité qui sont liés. On a aussi le cynisme non politique, donc en général, qu'on est plus cynique que l'autre.
Cette méfiance, ça peut aussi être plus général, plus généralisé envers tout le monde, envers nos voisins, envers, par exemple, même nos amis ou des personnes qui sont dans notre propre groupe, dans nos réseaux.
Donc c'est pas forcément un phénomène strictement politique.
Non.
Et donc tu dis, tu as pas encore fait de recherches là-dessus, donc tu sais pas exactement si c'est un truc-
Non, je pense qu'il y a des traits de personnalité, par exemple, qui nous rendent plus inclinés de supporter ou de devenir plus cyniques au niveau politique.
Il y aura sans doute aussi des-
Ça explique pas une tendance sociétale, ça. C'est au niveau individuel.
Peut-être que des problèmes économiques peuvent stimuler, en général, le cynisme ou stimuler le cynisme politique parmi quelques personnes, mais pas parmi d'autres.
Donc, on a toujours cette interaction entre ce qui se passe au niveau personnel et au niveau sociétal. Et la dynamique entre ces deux rend les choses très très intéressantes, je trouve.
Voilà, donc il y a certainement des explications pour ce cynisme, mais alors, il faudrait plutôt en parler avec des gens qui travaillent dans le socioéconomique, des politologues, etc.
pour regarder les tendances de ces vingt, trente, quarante dernières années, expliquer un petit peu ce qui pourrait expliquer le, oui, le déclin en termes de confiance, le fait qu'on soit de plus en plus méfiant.
Mais je vais juste faire le lien avec autre chose, c'est que ce manque de confiance, c'est pas réservé aux politiques, puisqu'on observe que c'est aussi, par exemple, les journalistes qui sont très fort
critiqués, détestés, et tout ce qui est un petit peu les--
au-dessus de la mêlée, médiatiquement, les gens qui ont de la visibilité, un sentiment anti-élite, en fait.
Ah oui, oui, oui. Ça, quand on parle de populisme, il y a plusieurs dimensions là-dedans et l'anti-élitisme, c'est une dimension très très importante.
L'autre, c'est par exemple qu'il y a deux groupes dans la société, le peuple et-
Les minorités, ouais.
Et donc, oui, et que la politique doit écouter le peuple et qu'il y a une volonté générale qui doit être exprimée par les politiciens, politiciennes.
Et disons, la perception que ça manque maintenant, qu'il n'y a pas de représentativité, etc., etc.
Et ce sentiment anti-élite, tu t'intéressais à savoir d'où ça vient ?
Oui, oui.
Dis-moi, je suis très curieux.
Mais à nouveau, oui, c'est une question assez ouverte encore, je pense.
parce que beaucoup de personnes ici dans notre centre font des recherches aussi sur les théories du complot et pourquoi il y a certaines personnes qui
ont tendance à croire beaucoup de-- ou supporter, endosser des théories et pourquoi pas.
On avait fait un super épisode avec Olivier Klein là-dessus.
Ah oui, oui, voilà.
C'est un grand spécialiste en la matière. Mais donc beaucoup de gens qui travaillent un petit peu sur tous ces sujets, mais donc spécifiquement sur le sentiment anti-élite.
Tu as une explication ?
Une explication ? Oui, à nouveau, ça peut être un peu un mélange de plusieurs facteurs. Je dirais pas qu'au niveau personnalité, mais ce sont des hypothèses qui, selon moi, n'ont pas encore été testées.
Mais par exemple, le manque d'ouverture d'esprit, ça peut stimuler un peu ou le-- disons, au niveau cognitif, en anglais, on dit closed mindedness.
Donc, on est vraiment-- on s'enferme pour d'autres opinions, etc. Ça peut bien sûr inciter un petit peu plus ce sentiment anti-élitaire, etc.
Mh. Alors, je te sens très prudent, mais je vais proposer une théorie. Tu vas me dire si ça te semble absurde ou si c'est possible, hein, parce que je te sens très prudent.
Mais donc, closed mindedness, le fait d'être de plus en plus fermé d'esprit, donc ça favorise ce sentiment anti-élite, c'est très intéressant.
Et donc une évolution sociétale importante de ces vingt dernières années, c'est évidemment les réseaux sociaux.
Mh.
Et on a beaucoup parlé du fait qu'on a des algorithmes très puissants sur Facebook, TikTok, Instagram, etc. pour un petit peu nous montrer des choses qui nous plaisent, des idées qui vont dans notre sens,
qui peut-être renforcent alors cette idée de closed mindedness, de-- on est de plus en plus fermé d'esprit quand on est confronté à une idée qui sort de ça.
Et donc, sentiment anti-élite de ça. Est-ce que ça te semble probable ? Est-ce que ça te semble crédible ?
Oui, très probable.
Ok, ben voilà.
Oui, c'est vrai. Même les études classiques montrent que sur la polarisa--
polarisation des groupes, montrent qu'après une discussion, les gens en général, en moyenne, vont plus vers les extrêmes et vont être plus sûrs de leurs opinions parce que, et ben, il y a cette
dynamique aussi qu'on veut suivre les normes dans le groupe.
Et si on-- après un débat ou une discussion parmi des amis, etc., on voit qu'ils sont plus, par exemple, à droite ou à gauche, on va aussi essayer de s'aligner avec le groupe ou les normes.
Et en plus, il y a cette idée de, ben, de connaissance, de-- le plus d'arguments on reçoit par-- moi, je connais pas tous les arguments ou tout le,
de certaines parties, mais le plus qu'on-- que je parle ou le plus que je lis sur Facebook ou n'importe quel réseau, le plus que je deviens
sûr, mais aussi le plus que je deviens extrême, par exemple.
Et c'est vrai que ces études ont été faites dans les années soixante et septante, mais aujourd'hui, on a cette, ben, les réseaux sociaux qui stimulent, comme tu dis, les silos politiques et
Oui, c'est vrai que ça peut vraiment bloquer notre vision et on va essayer de confirmer.
Donc c'est le biais de confirmation. On va essayer de confirmer notre opinion et de ne pas regarder ou même ignorer qu'il y a d'autres opinions ou qu'il y a d'autres, par exemple,
papiers ou évidences qui montrent que notre opinion n'est peut-être pas complètement correcte.
Ouais. Et est-ce que, donc, on dit voilà, les silos, les bulles, on reste avec des gens qui ont des idées compatibles, des idées qui nous plaisent.
Est-ce qu'alors ensuite, on observe que dans la façon dont les gens construisent leur réseau social, leurs groupes sociaux en dehors des réseaux sociaux, donc dans la vraie vie, les gens avec qui ils vont passer du temps,
les gens avec qui ils vont discuter, les gens qu'ils vont voir, est-ce qu'on observe que ces vingt dernières années, on a shifté vers
passer peut-être plus de temps
vraiment en dehors des réseaux sociaux, avec des gens qui sont, qui nous ressemblent, qui pensent comme nous ?
Oui. Il y a des études là-dedans qui, ou là-dessus, qui montrent que ce principe de homophilie, c'est vraiment on aime ce qui est comme nous.
C'est un processus qui joue un rôle, par exemple quand on cherche des nouveaux amis ou quand on commence, par exemple à l'université, à trouver notre propre réseau, etc., etc.
Et donc, avec une doctorante, on est en train de regarder comment les climats idéologiques, donc comment les personnes qui sont importantes pour nous, peuvent influencer nos propres attitudes politiques.
Et donc, oui, c'est vraiment, on ne peut pas négliger ce qui se passe dans nos groupes ou dans nos réseaux qui sont importants, surtout les groupes d'amis et la famille.
Ces deux silos la famille, on ne peut pas vraiment choisir, mais ils ont une grande influence idéologique.
et cela, tout cela encore plus quand, comme je viens de dire, on trouve que les normes de nos-- notre groupe sont importantes et quand on est fier de notre identité, par exemple dans un certain groupe et on va, on veut
être comme eux, on veut s'exprimer comme ils et elles sont, etc.
Oui oui. Donc, on disait une société avec de plus en plus closed mindedness, de plus en plus fermée d'esprit. Homophilie, donc on veut rester avec des gens qui nous ressemblent.
On veut rester dans quelque chose qui correspond à la norme sociale du groupe dans lequel on est. Est-ce qu'alors ça veut dire que c'est de plus en plus dur pour les gens de trouver des amis puisqu'ils sont de plus en plus
renfermés sur leurs propres fonctionnements ou leurs propres idées ?
Oui, mais je crois quand même qu'après quelques minutes, qu'on a rencontré quelqu'un nouveau, on peut déjà estimer...
Oui, il faut faire l'effort, ça, c'est vrai. Mais bon, on soupçonne souvent ou l'on perçoit souvent que quelqu'un a une idéologie ou un, disons, une vision du monde un peu comme nous ou pas.
Ou souvent, on devient ami parce qu'on a un ami en commun, etc., etc. Donc comme ça, je pense pas que... Bah, il y a des études, mais c'est surtout des sociologues qui ont trouvé que
y a plus de solitude aussi dans la société qu'avant et qu'on ne connaît pas beaucoup de personnes au-delà de notre famille et notre travail, de lieu de travail.
Et donc c'est ça la troisième dimension qui manque, donc c'est vrai que les gens, de moins en moins, vont dans un parc par exemple, juste pour lire ou pour s'asseoir et chill un petit peu.
C'est vraiment quelque chose qui se passe, bah, moins souvent qu'avant. Et donc, il y a ce livre que j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle Bowling Alone.
C'est un livre qui date des années nonante, je crois même, mais qui montre que oui, la société est en train de changer quand même un petit peu. Et aussi,
quand on est dans un groupe, je sais pas si-- maintenant, je parle un petit peu de mes propres anecdotes, mais
ça m'embête vraiment qu'il y a beaucoup de personnes sur leur téléphone, même si on est dans un groupe et on a une vraie conversation, en vrai.
Donc c'est, oui, c'est quand même quelque chose de bizarre, sans dire que c'est le moteur principal du cynisme ou de radicalisme ou populisme, etc.
Ça participe.
Oui.
Ok. Donc on observe donc toutes ces évolutions vraiment au niveau sociétal. Je vais revenir sur le sujet d'aujourd'hui, à savoir la psychologie politique.
Donc ce cynisme, qui voilà, qui est en partie lié à tout ce qu'on vient d'évoquer, est-ce qu'y a certains partis politiques, par exemple en Belgique, puisqu'on est en Belgique, qui surfent un peu plus là-dessus que d'autres ?
Et comment est-ce que tu-- qu'est-ce que tu observes à ce niveau-là ?
Oui. Oui, on trouve que le cynisme, c'est le-- quand on regarde les prédicteurs de soutien pour certains partis, on trouve que le cynisme, c'est le plus important pour certains partis.
Et dans notre contexte politique, c'est souvent des partis d'extrême. Quand on a fait des études en Flandre, mais aussi aux Pays-Bas.
Et là, on trouve que le support pour les partis d'extrême droite, en Flandre, c'est Vlaams Belang, Partij voor de Vrijheid, de Geert Wilders aux Pays-Bas, et même d'autres Forum voor Democratie qui étaient populaires à l'époque,
sont tous prédits ou le soutien, le support pour ces partis-là sont tous prédits par plusieurs choses, mais une des plus importantes dimensions, c'est le cynisme politique ou le sentiment anti-établissement.
Quand on fait des études ici, bah, au niveau Belgique francophone, là, on trouve que c'est surtout le PTB qui surfe un petit peu sur ce sentiment du populisme, même si c'est moins prononcé.
Et donc, on a essayé de mettre toutes ces pièces du puzzle ensemble pour voir est-ce qu'on voit des tendances. Et donc
le modèle qu'on essaie d'appliquer ou qu'on propose maintenant, c'est que y a des,
disons, des facteurs qui distinguent le support pour certaines parties qui sont, disons, plutôt en commun, plutôt même universels, entre guillemets.
Et c'est par exemple le conservatisme socioculturel, qu'on appelle autoritarisme, donc l'obéissance dans toutes les sociétés, le support pour des idées plutôt traditionnelles, etc.
Et une agressivité ou même une, ben disons, surtout une négativité envers ceux et celles qui ne se conforment pas aux normes.
Deuxièmement, il y a ce, disons, conservatisme plutôt économique, hiérarchique, qu'on trouve que c'est normal que la société n'est pas égale et qu'il y a certains groupes qui sont plus en haut et d'autres qui sont plus en bas
sur l'escalier, entre guillemets.
Troisièmement, donc, le populisme ou surtout le cynisme envers la politique. Ces trois-là sont déjà-
Quand on a ces données-là, on peut prédire pour qui la personne va voter.
Oui, oui, avec une certaine proportion de certitude, je dirais. Mais il y a des choses uniques. Et là, ce sont des nouveaux thèmes ou plutôt des alignements qui
sont uniques, peut-être dans certains contextes, mais aussi pour certaines parties.
Par exemple, quand on regarde l'extrême droite, là, une des motivations, on en a pas parlé encore, c'est la migration.
Bien sûr.
Et là, ça va pas diminuer l'effet d'autres prédicteurs, des idéologies et du cynisme, etc. Mais ça va encore au-delà des prédicteurs qu'on connaisse,
ben, augmenter la variance qu'on peut expliquer dans le support pour la droite versus extrême droite, par exemple.
Au niveau de la psychologie de l'extrême gauche, là, on trouve que la migration, c'est pas vraiment un thème qui joue un rôle.
Ben, c'est plutôt-
Sentiments anti, anticapitalistes.
Oui, mais l'anticapitalisme, c'est, là, c'est, disons, la particularité qui prédit encore plus au-delà de, par exemple, le populisme ou le-
Oui. Donc, si on a des convictions fortement anti-immigration, on peut difficilement voter pour quelqu'un d'autre que le Vlaams Belang.
Si on est vraiment anticapitaliste, on vote plutôt PVDA, et,
et, ou PTB. Ça, ça me semble difficile. Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est que, donc on a eu des élections très récemment et donc on a vu que par exemple, le PTB, le PVDA avait monté en Flandre.
Il est monté à Bruxelles en termes de score. En fait, il a baissé en Wallonie, ce qui a surpris tout le monde.
Et donc ça indique qu'y a des électeurs qui ont voté la dernière fois, la fois d'avant pour le PTB, mais qui n'étaient pas forcément des anticapitalistes convaincus, et qui étaient plutôt là, alors, peut-être
par cynisme, peut-être par un côté, on donne un coup dans la fourmilière, il faut que ça change.
Mmh-mmh.
Et voilà. Et alors, ce qu'on observe, c'est qu'ils sont peut-être passés plutôt au Mouvement Réformateur. Ça, c'est intéressant.
Est-ce que, donc ce que tu disais, voilà, qui surfe sur le cynisme du côté francophone ?
Ouais.
Plutôt le PTB.
Ah oui.
Est-ce que ça aurait pas un petit peu changé récemment ?
Peut-être que oui, parce qu'on dit souvent : « Les extrêmes se touchent ». Et donc, dans le CVPol, ici à l'ULB, donc c'est le Centre de la Vie Politique, quelque chose comme ça.
Donc certaines études de ce centre-là ont montré qu'y a beaucoup de mouvements entre-- ou, pardon, y a beaucoup de personnes qui ont voté, par exemple, pour PTB, qui vont dans l'autre direction.
Et souvent, ils vont soit très très proche,
vers la PS, par exemple, ou très très loin. Et donc, c'est,
ça peut sembler un peu bizarre, mais c'est surtout parce qu'y a des motivations en commun qui sous-tendent, par exemple, le support pour, disons, PTB et MR, ou en Flandre, PVDA et Vlaams Belang.
Et donc c'est pas illogique qu'il y a ce mouvement qui semble un petit peu bizarre ou difficile à expliquer.
Mais bon, c'est quelque chose qui, quand on parle des motivations en commun versus plutôt uniques, ce sont des motivations en commun qui peuvent expliquer-
Qu'est-ce que ce serait alors, ces motivations en commun entre le PTB et le MR ?
Ben, le cynisme, mais maintenant, je me demande, donc le MR était dans le gouvernement, donc c'est pas vraiment un sentiment anti-établissement parce qu'ils sont-
C'est la particularité, c'est qu'ils ont fait participe opposition. Ils étaient dans le gouvernement, mais ils arrêtaient pas de dire que le gouvernement était nul.
Oui.
Donc c'est peut-être ça qui a joué. C'est peut-être ça, on critiquait beaucoup le président du MR pour ça,
mais je crois qu'il a compris que le cynisme était un facteur important dans les élections.
Ouais, tout à fait.
Oui, oui. Donc, voilà, on disait, le PTB, le Vlaams Belang surfent beaucoup là-dessus. Est-ce que la N-VA surfe aussi sur le cynisme ou pas tellement ?
Selon nos données, moins.
OK.
Même si bien sûr,
y a certains politiciens et politiciennes dans ce parti-là qui, selon le thème, vont utiliser un peu de cynisme-
Par exemple, quand, bah c'est peut-être un processus plus large qu'au niveau politique, mais quand des membres de notre groupe le font bien, c'est nous.
Par exemple, quand les Diables Rouges gagnent, c'est nous qui a gagné, qui ont gagné. Et donc, quand ça va pas bien, c'est toujours eux ou c'est-
Oui oui, on divise encore plus quand ça va pas.
Et donc peut-être, quand on parle de,
disons, une décision qui a été prise surtout par les partis verts,
peut-être que la N-VA peut utiliser ce populisme pour-- en disant : « Non, non, c'est pas nous, c'est eux qui ont fait cette décision qui n'est pas tout à fait la meilleure, etc., etc. »
Oui. Et une autre différence importante aussi pour parler de la mobilité des électeurs qui peuvent passer d'un parti à l'autre, c'est qu'avant, on disait vraiment qu'on avait été dans une Belgique pilarisée.
On était dans le pilier chrétien, on allait à l'école catholique, on avait une mutualité chrétienne, etc., etc. Et donc c'était de père en fils, on vote pour le parti catholique.
Et que maintenant, on est de plus en plus éloigné de ça. Voilà, peut-être des générations plus anciennes qui restent encore très attachées aux partis auxquels ils sont attachés.
Mais ils sont attachés aux partis auxquels ils sont attachés. Finalement, en fait, c'est un peu ça, hein. Et donc voilà.
Et maintenant, de plus en plus de mobilité, donc, jusqu'à, voilà, même du PTB jusqu'au Mouvement Réformateur.
OK, ben donc, le sentiment de cynisme qui est un facteur très important, est-ce que le sentiment de cynisme va jusqu'à expliquer, par exemple, la radicalisation ?
Quand on est vraiment à être en faveur de presque la violence ou presque une révolution, des choses comme ça, est-ce que le cynisme peut aller jusque-là ?
Oui, je pense que, ben on a des exemples historiques, mais c'est vrai qu'au niveau psychologique, que c'est le déterminant pour devenir plus extrême.
Et ça veut dire non seulement au niveau de nos attitudes, mais aussi au niveau de changer la société, par exemple, et de se mobiliser, par exemple, pour faire de l'action collective, pour être, bah, signer des pétitions.
Ça, ça va encore, mais pour s-- aller dans les rues et de faire des démonstrations souvent violentes, etc.
etc. Oui. Juste pour retourner au point des familles, des supports politiques, c'est très intéressant parce que c'est une hypothèse,
je peux pas tester, mais je crois que, ben le succès électoral des Engagés peut être expliqué de fait qu'ils ont changé de nom et que le, ben le lien avec la religion catholique, etc.,
c'est encore là, mais c'est un peu disparu, c'est un peu caché même.
Oui, tout à fait. Ils ont, voilà, Jean-Luc Crucke, voilà, libéral social plutôt, donc ils ont un petit peu changé leur positionnement.
Ils ont changé au Parlement européen de parti auquel ils s'étaient attachés. Mais je pense aussi que le fait d'avoir changé de nom,
ça leur permet de surfer sur ce cynisme et de dire : « Nous, on est frais, on est nouveaux, on est neufs », alors que c'est un parti qui existe depuis la création de la Belgique.
Ouais.
Voilà. Mais donc, donc voilà, je pense que ça peut être un facteur aussi.
Donc, une fois qu'on pose ce constat du cynisme, du populisme, de radicalisation parfois, est-ce que tu proposes une solution éventuellement ?
Comment est-ce que tu vois la suite des événements ?
Bah, souvent, quand on parle des solutions, il y a deux pistes, je crois, mais les deux pistes ne sont pas trop évidentes.
Première piste, c'est stimuler le contact entre des groupes différents, et par exemple, de vraiment aller de-dehors notre silo, notre boucle, et d'essayer de,
d'écouter de l'autre côté ce qui se passe et qui sont les choses qui doivent être améliorées, etc., etc.
Donc, ça peut être une initiative de la politique, d'aller dans les rues. On a des nouvelles élections pour octobre, donc de vraiment écouter nos voisins, etc.
Mais aussi une initiative au niveau individuel, qu'on est conscient qu'on a des biais, qu'on a des préjugés, etc.
Et que c'est très facile, à cause de ce principe, par exemple, d'homophilie, d'éviter de prendre contact avec ou d'écouter, de parler avec quelqu'un qui n'est pas comme nous.
Mais si on le fait, peut-être, on va avoir plus d'empathie, plus de-- on va plus être capable de prendre leur perspective, même si on n'est pas d'accord.
On peut quand même, ben essayer de comprendre d'où viennent leurs soucis, etc. Et deuxième piste, c'est plutôt réfléchir à notre identité.
Ça peut être notre identité politique, mais aussi plus globale ou plus, disons, supra-ordonnée. Donc, est-ce qu'on se sent plutôt Bruxellois, Flamand ou Wallon, ou est-ce qu'on se sent plutôt Belge, etc.
? Est-ce qu'on veut une société où il y a ces silos qui sont, par exemple, tous acceptés, si ça reste non violent, etc., mais qui se touchent pas ?
Ou est-ce qu'on veut plus de diversité ? Ou est-ce qu'on veut plus de ce qu'on appelle polyculturalisme, qu'on va plus mélanger les idées, etc., pour devenir avec quelque chose nouveau ?
Et donc, ben à nouveau, ça peut être une initiative que la politique fait ou prend, mais ça peut aussi devenir quelque chose de nous, parce que c'est nous, l'électorat qui
Qui va créer des conditions dans laquelle les politiciens, politiciennes travaillent.
Et donc c'est, oui, c'est quelque chose d'intéressant à réfléchir.
C'est une première piste spécifiquement pour la question de la polarisation. Ça, on va parler de la solution au cynisme peut-être juste après.
Mais donc, tu disais une ville très multiculturelle. Nous sommes justement à Bruxelles, donc deuxième ville la plus cosmopolite dans le monde, 60 % des résidents qui sont-- qui ont une nationalité étrangère, hum-
Qui est le premier, si je peux-
Dubaï.
Ah OK, OK.
Ah, tu savais pas ? Tu savais pas que Dubaï-- Bruxelles était aussi dans le classement ?
OK.
Voilà. Hum, on apprend des choses dans ce podcast, c'est fait pour ça. Et donc on a l'occasion de rencontrer, voilà, beaucoup des Européens, mais c'est aussi, voilà, les communautés issues du Maghreb, tout ça.
Hum, donc est-ce qu'alors, on arrive, comme tu le proposais, hein, ce constat que comme on a l'occasion de discuter avec des gens différents, des origines différentes, est-ce qu'on observe alors moins de polarisation à Bruxelles ?
Ça, c'est une bonne question. Je vais proposer cela comme thème de mémoire. Oui, ça m'intéresse beaucoup.
Et donc, oui, pendant mon doctorat, j'ai aussi exploré un petit peu la question de la diversité ethnoculturelle et comment les gens réagissent envers cette diversité.
On en a-- C'est là où l'idée de la polarisation a augmenté dans mes pensées et dans mes, ben, ce que j'ai écrit, parce qu'on a trouvé que dans des villes, villages, etc.
qui sont plus diversifiés, donc en termes de proportion de personnes issues de la migration, le plus qu'on a trouvé ces réponses extrêmes.
Donc, statistiquement, ce qu'on a trouvé que quand on demande, on pose la question : est-ce que vous souhaitez, par exemple, plus de migration ou non ?
Ou est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec la phrase : j'aime beaucoup les personnes issues de la migration. Complètement en désaccord, une, complètement d'accord, cinq.
Et toutes les options au milieu. Et donc, ce qu'on a trouvé, et c'était une étude aux Pays-Bas, parmi des personnes qui habitent dans les cinquante villes les plus diversifiées.
On a trouvé que,
dans Amsterdam, Rotterdam, etc. où il y avait beaucoup de personnes issues de la migration, que là, il y a plus de polarisation en termes de réponses
une, complètement en désaccord, complètement contre la migration, mais aussi en proportion de cinq,
qui sont très pro la migration, qui sont ouvertes à les accueillir, à apprendre, par exemple, des autres coutumes culturelles, etc., etc.
Donc le milieu n'était moins présent dans des quartiers ou dans des villes plus diversifiées, ce qui est intéressant.
On dit toujours average Joe. Et donc c'est--
Quand on regarde les chiffres, il y a encore beaucoup de personnes au milieu, sans doute, mais moins que, ou plus dans des villes qui n'ont pas de diversité, qui sont plus homogènes, etc.
Et donc, je me demande, à Bruxelles, il y a les conditions vraiment qui offrent les pistes envers la solution, entre guillemets. Donc-
Donc c'est intéressant, parce que moi, j'aurais pensé le contraire. C'est quand on a l'occasion de rencontrer des gens issus de l'immigration, des étrangers, hum, on est plus polarisé que le contraire.
C'est-- J'ai bien compris ? On est moins au milieu.
Oui, oui, mais c'est quelque chose qui se passe entre nous. Donc,
par exemple, si moi, je suis un peu plus négatif, par exemple, envers la migration, si j'habite à Bruxelles, je vais devenir peut-être quelqu'un qui dit un.
Et si tu, par exemple, es plus pro, tu deviens encore plus convaincu-
Ça accélère le, voilà, ça donne un petit coup d'accélérateur dans le-
Oui, et c'est plutôt un facteur de consolidation de notre propre opinion.
C'est ça.
Oui.
Ce que j'allais dire, donc on peut observer les résultats électoraux, justement, à Bruxelles. Et donc, comme je disais, le PTB a monté.
Hum, alors évidemment, c'est-- Il faut nuancer parce que tout ça est très compliqué. Il y a l'histoire de Good Move, les histoires de politique vis-à-vis de l'abattage des animaux, etc.
Enfin, c'est-- On ne peut pas juste regarder le facteur du cynisme ou de la multiculturalité. Il y a aussi le fait que les, ben les étrangers, en fait, ne votent pas.
Donc ça, c'est un facteur important. Hum, mais donc, en fait, les partis qui ont monté, c'est effectivement le PTB et le MR.
Donc effectivement moins ceux qui sont au milieu.
Oui.
Voilà.
Oui. Sauf dans la communauté f-néerlandophone.
Ah oui, oui.
Là, c'est Groen qui-
C'était, hum, Fouad Ahidar. Oui, c'est ça. Donc lui, et puis Groen aussi.
Oui, oui, tout à fait. Même si lui, peut-être, peut être considéré comme populiste, mais je sais pas trop parce que je connais pas son programme de-
Et lui, il a clairement été chercher des francophones pour aller voter sur les listes néerlandophones, histoire d'avoir un boost, ce qui est une technique qui n'est pas tout à fait démocratique, mais ça va.
Oui, c'est, oui, c'est un peu bizarre. Ben c'est unique dans le contexte bruxellois.
Parce qu'on a un système institutionnel un peu, voilà, qui penche un petit peu pour favoriser la communauté néerlandophone.
Oui, en termes de numériquement, de proportion, plus la représentation, oui. Oui.
Oui, et là, il en a profité. Alors qu'il est bilingue, mais je pense qu'il a été chercher des voix.
Oui, il était-- il faisait partie de SPA, donc Vooruit avant qu'ils ont changé leur nom et...
Ouais. Voilà, mais donc voilà, c'est un exemple à Bruxelles qui peut-être effectivement va dans ce sens, effectivement, du côté francophone, plutôt.
Donc voilà, tu-- On parlait de- Solution-
Oui
...de ce qu'on observait vis-à-vis de la polarisation. Tu disais peut-être plus rencontrer des gens, mais en fait, finalement, tu me dis : « Quand on rencontre des gens différents, on a un coup d'accélérateur ».
C'est, est-ce que j'ai mal compris ?
Oui.
Vas-y, vas-y, dis-moi.
C'est très chouette qu'on parle de ce point-là. J'ai parlé de ce qui se passe dans des quartiers ou des villes diversifiées.
Mais donc la diversité n'est pas égale au contact intergroupe.
C'est vrai.
Et donc c'est là où on trouve que-
Particulièrement à Bruxelles.
Il y a cette autoségrégation, par exemple, où il y a des quartiers, par exemple, où il y a beaucoup de diversité, mais d'autres, où il y en a, où il y a peu. Et donc
pour plusieurs raisons hein, des raisons économiques, etc. Mais aussi de, ben, la question de cette homophilie, on--
même dans des quartiers diversifiés, souvent, on va être capable à éviter des contacts avec des personnes qui ne sont pas comme nous.
Cela étant dit, quand on peut, ben aller au-delà de la ségrégation et vraiment mélanger des quartiers, par exemple, vraiment stimuler des contacts intergroupe, ça peut être une partie de la solution, vraiment.
Mais ça, c'est assez rare de trouver des... Ben si on peut faire la combinaison entre diversité, donc une représentation des personnes issues de la migration, par exemple, et beaucoup de contacts entre,
les groupes dans la société, peut-être là, on peut surpasser cette polarité.
Mais donc c'est intéressant puisqu'alors, on observe donc à Bruxelles, je théorise hein.
Oui.
Mais on observe à Bruxelles que donc PTB et MR, donc, qui surfent vraisemblablement plutôt sur le cynisme et sur cette envie de changement anti-- voilà, un peu anti-establishment,
d'une certaine manière, même si pour le MR, c'est particulier.
Et donc qui serait alors un exemple de, puisque Bruxelles a beaucoup de diversité, ce serait alors la preuve mathématiquement que,
encore une fois, c'est un facteur parmi d'autres, mais que les différents groupes sociaux à Bruxelles ne se parlent pas forcément, qu'ils restent entre eux.
Et donc, ils ont de plus en plus des idées qui vont, ben, ils se-- les différents groupes sociaux vont valider leurs propres idées, vont se retrancher sur leurs propres convictions.
Et donc, et donc alors, on voit peut-être augmenter les scores des partis qui surfent sur le cynisme.
Ouais.
Ce serait ça ?
Oui, mais c'est-- à nouveau, ça me semble tout à fait normal et humain de préférer ce qui est comme toi ou de préférer un peu ce qui était le cas déjà, pendant des années, des années, etc.
Et donc, tu as aussi utilisé le mot multiculturel. Ça, c'est à nouveau quelque chose qui est lié à cette identité.
Et donc le multiculturalisme n'égale pas ou n'est pas égal à la diversité, par exemple.
D'accord.
Et donc, pour moi, le multiculturalisme, c'est une des stratégies, une des, disons, des mesures pour traiter la diversité.
Donc, on en a plusieurs, on peut donner des exemples
de l'Afrique du Sud, par exemple, qui a, à l'époque, avec l'apartheid, choisi de traiter la diversité parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de diversité, qui ont dit : « Ah oui, on va ségréger la société, etc.
On veut un monoculturalisme avec une culture, la culture blanche, qui est la norme » et tout le reste est en dehors, est marginalisé.
On ne trouve pas cette stratégie à Bruxelles ou en Belgique de cette façon. Le multiculturalisme, ce sont les silos,
les cultures séparées qui sont acceptées d'être là, qui font partie de la société, mais comme j'ai dit, qui ne se touchent pas vraiment.
Et donc l'interculturalisme, là, on a vraiment l'attitude ou le policy de faire rencontrer ces groupes-là, mais ce n'est pas facile.
Et à Bruxelles, on est plutôt interculturalisme ou plutôt multiculturel ? Parce que moi, j'ai l'impression qu'on—
On est diversifié.
Oui, j'ai l'impression qu'on, ouais, qu'on reste très fort entre nous et que, voilà, on est... Les gens qui habitent à Uccle ou à Woluwe ne connaissent pas forcément beaucoup de gens qui habitent à Laeken et à Molenbeek.
Ouais. Oui, oui.
Voilà. Très bien. Mais donc, tout ça, c'est vis-à-vis de la polarisation.
Mmm-hmm.
Donc si on va toucher maintenant au cynisme, ce sentiment donc qui est de plus en plus constaté, anti-système, anti-establishment, méfiance, voilà.
Là, est-ce que tu as une idée de comment est-ce qu'on pourrait procéder pour un petit peu s'attaquer au cynisme ?
Ouais. Oui, à nouveau, une question très très intéressante qui n'a pas de réponse facile, mais rétablir la confiance d'une certaine manière, ça sera le job numéro uno pour la politique.
Surtout parce que si on regarde aussi dans d'autres pays, les chiffres et qui supporte ou qui a confiance dans le gouvernement, etc., ça tombe et ça tombe.
Donc, je pense qu'il faut resocialiser les gens dans le système gouvernemental, dans la démocratie. Beaucoup de gens ne supportent plus la démocratie et veulent qu'il y ait un autre système.
Ici en Belgique aussi, qui veulent plutôt quelque chose d'autoritaire, etc. Ou avec des, pas des sondages, mais des votes comme en Suisse.
Ah oui, des, des—
Référendum.
Référendum, c'est ça, ou des votations, tout ça.
Oui.
Oui. Et un autre truc qu'on observe, c'est des gens qui sont déçus de— parce qu'on a une démocratie très très représentative, on a plein de parlements, on a— tous les électeurs belges doivent voter obligatoirement.
Et donc voilà. Et puis ensuite, tout le monde se dispute pour faire des coalitions. Mais il y en a qui voteraient pour— qui auraient envie qu'on dise : le premier en termes de score, c'est lui qui a le pouvoir tout seul.
Donc c'est— bon, ce n'est pas tout à fait autoritaire, mais c'est un peu moins la démocratie très bureaucratique qu'on a.
Un peu comme aux États-Unis, que the winner takes it all part.
Ou la France, oui.
Oui, oui, là-bas aussi.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Même si là, on voit aussi cette polarisation très très visible—
Oui
...dans les deux côtés.
Ils découvrent ce que c'est la Belgique.
Ouais.
OK, mais donc, pour revenir sur le, qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour s'attaquer au cynisme ?
Ouais. Peut-être, quand tu parlais des coalitions, peut-être là, il y a le problème qu'il n'y a pas vraiment d'efficacité dans le gouvernement.
Ah oui.
Il y a beaucoup de discussions, beaucoup de débats, etc. Et on reste là. Et donc les—
Inertie très forte, ouais.
Oui, oui. Et toutes les décisions importantes sont reposées ou reportées pour le prochain gouvernement, etc. Et donc, c'est là, je crois, mais c'est plutôt anecdotique, que la plupart des cyniques politiques ont trouvé leur,
disons, le défi le plus important ou leur,
leur méfiance, leur colère même, vient de ce débat éternel qui ne propose pas de solutions concrètes, parce qu'il y a des problèmes dans notre société, il y en a plusieurs.
Et donc chaque problème pour lequel le gouvernement ne propose pas de solutions peut être utilisé comme motivation par d'autres partis—
C'est ça. Et aussi le fait qu'on doit souvent former des coalitions avec des socialistes et des libéraux ou des... 'fin, voilà, c'est un peu là-dessus que ça bloque en ce moment, au niveau fédéral.
Ça fait que, inévitablement, il y a des évolutions très très lentes où c'est difficile de dire : « Maintenant, on va faire un changement
très à gauche ou un changement très à droite » puisqu'il y a forcément des blocages et c'est ce qu'on observe pour le moment.
Ouais.
Et donc cette inertie renforce le cynisme.
Oui, oui.
Oui.
Je pense que oui, oui, tout à fait.
Ouais, mais donc c'est très compliqué parce que je demandais une solution, moi. Je voulais une solution.
Je pense qu'il n'y a pas de composition idéale parce que—
Est-ce que quand on arrive sur des systèmes plus autocrates, plus winner takes it all, etc., est-ce que là, on observe que, ben il y a moins d'inertie et moins de cynisme ?
Peut-être que oui, mais même là, on trouve que souvent, ça revient au milieu. Peut-être, quand on regarde, par exemple, à nouveau les États-Unis, je suis désolé, mais—
Non, c'est normal.
Des études ont été faites là-bas, tous les changements qui ont été introduits par Barack Obama à l'époque, Obamacare, par exemple, ont été, ben, opposés ou même annulés par Trump et vice versa.
Donc, on se trouve peut-être avec plus de decisiveness, mais peut-être, mais peut-être—
Oui, une inertie, mais peut-être plus sur une dizaine d'années que sur une semaine. OK, mais par exemple, je pense à,
ben la Hongrie de Viktor Orbán ou la Pologne, des exemples comme ça où ils ont vraiment été très très à droite.
Est-ce que là— est-ce que les Hongrois et les Polonais sont cyniques ? Ou bien est-ce que...
Oui. Je pense que là, peut-être qu'on va un peu trouver l'inverse, mais je n'ai pas lu ou je n'ai pas fait d'études dans ce contexte-là.
Mais maintenant, par exemple, en Hongrie,
disons, le conservatisme est devenu la norme plutôt. Et donc les cyniques qui sont contre l'établissement vont peut-être être plus progressistes, et contre le gouvernement de, ou les mesures que Orbán a prises.
En Pologne, ça peut être un peu plus nuancé encore, parce que là, ce n'est pas vraiment une partie qui a gagné tout.
Mais c'est vrai que là, il y a beaucoup de prédicteurs de support pour certaines politiques ou pour certaines parties.
Et je pense que l'identité polonaise, disons, catholique, est très très importante là pour soit soutenir ou non le gouvernement.
Mais quand on parle de la diversité, là, on a eu beaucoup de démonstrations, par exemple pro LGBTQI+, etc., qui montrent que même dans cette société-là qui a l'air d'être plus homogène ou plus,
ou moins inertie, que— même là, on trouve qu'il y a des personnes qui ne sont pas d'accord avec les mesures et qui vont démontrer, se manifester, etc.
Donc, il y a cette, je pense, peut-être c'est une polarisation, peut-être non, mais—
Ouais, c'est compliqué à dire. Mais donc, on revient sur cette idée que les longues négociations qu'on a en Belgique, cette inertie, ça renforce le cynisme.
Mais donc, encore une fois, qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour aider ce cynisme ?
Oui, parce que— oui, oui. C'est une très belle question parce que je trouve même que ce n'est pas mal, en théorie, d'avoir une variance en termes d'idées et d'attitudes.
Et si tout le monde pense la même chose, ben bon, on va prendre des décisions très très vite, mais ce ne sont peut-être pas les meilleures décisions.
Donc le fait qu'en Belgique, mais aussi dans d'autres démocraties, on accepte les divergences et on va essayer, pardon, de trouver une solution.
C'est quelque chose qu'on doit quand même stimuler, qu'on doit apprendre à peut-être apprécier.
Oui, oui, ce n'est pas une critique de ma part, hein, mais donc je cherche ce que les politiciens, les politiciennes peuvent faire pour résoudre ou améliorer la situation vis-à-vis du cynisme. Est-ce que—
Bah, peut-être encore plus mettre en évidence leurs résultats, parce que souvent, on a l'impression qu'il n'y en a pas ou pas beaucoup.
Et, ou montrer et redéfinir ce qu'ils ont fait qui était pas mal. Par exemple, des décisions qui ont été prises pendant la crise COVID.
Il y avait des mesures et on peut en parler si c'était des mesures, les meilleures mesures ou non, mais qui ont quand même baissé le nombre de cas, etc.
Qui ont été prises, pardon, assez vite. Et là, le gouvernement peut réfléchir ou peut même à nouveau mettre en évidence : « Ah, regarde ce qu'on a fait là.
» Si on veut, c'est vraiment nécessaire, on peut aider la société—
Mieux communiquer, avoir le meilleur PR au gouvernement pour, voilà, pour montrer les résultats.
Mais à nouveau, je ne sais pas si les cyniques regardent la RTBF ou la VRT souvent. Donc peut-être qu'ils ont leur propre réseau d'infos, plutôt en ligne, sur Facebook ou d'autres—
Peut-être qu'ils ne seront jamais atteints par le message de—
Ouais.
Les services publics. Hum, OK. En fait, je reviens tout le temps sur cette question de comment améliorer le cynisme, parce que dans un papier de recherche que tu as publié, tu parles,
tu estimes que les politiques devraient s'excuser.
Oui, ça peut être aussi un bon début. Peut-être pas s'excuser, mais—
Reconnaître—
Oui.
Ouais, reconnaître qu'ils n'ont pas géré.
Oui, effectivement. Bah, ça dépend un petit peu des thèmes qu'on regarde, mais dans plusieurs niveaux, ils ont raté.
Et si c'était un examen ici à l'ULB, ça, c'était moins que 10 sur 20, par exemple. Et donc, je pense que c'est un bon début d'être honnête et de dire : « OK, la façon dont on a pris certaines décisions n'était pas idéale.
On s'excuse et on propose une nouvelle solution ici.
» C'est difficile, bien sûr, et je pense que ça, on a parlé des tendances humaines, par exemple, de chercher ce qui est comme nous, etc., de s'autoriser la ségrégation, etc.
Je pense que, disons, la tendance à ne pas se pardonner est plus large que d'être capable de vraiment reconnaître qu'on était, ouais.
Je ne sais pas si un parti qui, au moment des élections, dit : « On n'a pas été très bon, désolé. » Je ne suis pas sûr que ça marche très bien après pour avoir des votes.
Ouais. Oui, peut-être juste après, parce qu'en Flandre, par exemple, le VLD a été—
Oui, oui.
Détruit, presque.
Presque, ouais.
Et là, le Premier ministre—
Il a pleuré.
S'est— oui, il s'est excusé, il a dit : « Non, donc on va vraiment recommencer... »
Oui, ap— mais après un échec.
Oui, oui, oui.
C'est ça.
Donc là, c'est plus facile, bien sûr, de passer—
Et du côté des libéraux francophones, donc si on part du principe qu'on a cette lecture de dire qu'ils ont surfé sur l'anti-establishment, sur l'envie de changement, la critique constante, etc., c'est l'opposé, en fait.
On ne peut pas faire ça et s'excuser—
Ah oui.
D'avoir mal géré juste après. Enfin, c'est, donc c'est deux stratégies très, très opposées.
Ouais.
Et on voit qu'électoralement, ça a plutôt marché pour les francophones et pas trop pour—
Pour les néerlandophones, ouais.
Ouais, ouais.
OK, mais donc, cette notion de présenter ses excuses, est-ce qu'il n'y a pas presque un jugement de valeur de ta part ?
Si on dit : « Les partis traditionnels au centre, voilà, doivent s'ex— ou devraient ou pourraient s'excuser pour après être mieux perçus et diminuer le cynisme.
» Hum, cynisme qui va donc nourrir la polarisation et les extrêmes, voilà, donc le Vlaams Belang et le PTB.
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas, dans ton chef, dans ta personne, une idée de : « Les extrêmes, ce n'est pas bien. »
« Ce qui est mieux, c'est les partis traditionnels. »
Oui, c'est une observation très très utile de ta part aussi parce que je suis chercheur et j'essaie dans mes recherches d'être neutre ou aussi neutre que possible.
En même temps, je suis citoyen belge et je dois voter, je dois réfléchir aux partis aussi. Et c'est vrai que l'idée démocratique, c'est d'inclure toutes les opinions.
Donc aussi aller dans la discussion avec des personnes Vlaams Belang, avec des personnes ou des politiciens, politiciennes PTB, etc.
On a bien sûr, disons, des étapes historiques qui ont été prises ou des décisions comme le cordon sanitaire qui bloque pour l'instant une participation des extrêmes, surtout de l'extrême droite, dans notre gouvernement.
Et au niveau
scientifique, je me demande si c'est la meilleure solution et est-ce qu'on ne peut pas changer cela pour voir ce qui se passe quand les extrêmes sont dans le gouvernement et quand les extrêmes deviennent l'établissement ?
Et donc, est-ce qu'il est—
Il y a des exemples historiques qui montrent que c'est assez grave.
Non, non, mais donc si les cyniques changent quand il n'y a aucune raison—
C'est une curiosité de ta part en tant que chercheur.
Oui, oui. Donc je parle comme—
C'est ça.
Purement théorique.
Ouais, je pense qu'il y aurait d'autres conséquences nettement plus graves que la question du cynisme. Mais donc, donc oui, je disais,
tu disais, t'es à la fois chercheur, tu essayes de travailler de façon factuelle avec une certaine neutralité dans ton travail et en même temps, t'es citoyen belge.
Ouais.
Donc comment est-ce que tu combines les deux ?
Oui, c'est difficile parce que je sais que les questions qu'on se pose, même si après avoir posé cette question, tout ce qui se passe au niveau d'une étude, donc la récolte de données, les analyses,
le rapport qu'on écrit ou l'article scientifique qui a été publié,
tout cela est objectif ou neutre et on utilise vraiment des méthodes dures, on dit, des hard sciences.
Donc ce n'est pas juste : « Ah oui, je suis en train de réfléchir—
Tout ce que je fais depuis une heure avec toi là.
Oui. Non, ben non. Mais bon, je sais que d'où viennent nos questions, c'est une motivation souvent personnelle.
On a des biais.
Oui, on a des biais ou par exemple, si je me demande : « Ah oui, qu'est-ce qui arrive avec des membres des groupes stigmatisés en Belgique ?
est-ce que les gens réagissent plutôt en termes de solidarité ou est-ce qu'ils sont très très négatifs ? » Et d'où vient cette—
Le fait de choisir ce sujet, c'est déjà un biais de ta part qui dit que tu te préoccupes de ça.
Ça ne vient pas de n'importe où.
Voilà. On devine que tu ne votes pas pour le Vlaams Belang si tu choisis un sujet comme celui-là.
Oui, c'est difficile pour des personnes qui sont chaleureux, par exemple, envers des— même s'il y a des personnes issues de la migration qui votent Vlaams Belang—
Ouais.
Pour d'autres motifs ou peut-être même pour des motifs—
Anti-establishment.
Oui, mais aussi même préjugés qu'on est contre, par exemple, l'arrivée d'encore de nouveaux arrivés ou nouvelles arrivantes, parce qu'on est ici et
après quelques générations, par exemple, on est fier d'être dans le groupe belge.
Il y a peut-être cinquante ans, on avait beaucoup de discrimination contre les Italiens, par exemple. Il y avait des panneaux qui disaient : « Ce magasin est interdit aux chiens et aux Italiens.
» Aujourd'hui, on a des gens issus de cette communauté-là qui seraient plutôt anti-immigration.
Oui.
Donc voilà, c'est un cycle qui se répète.
Même si la diversité est moins visible là, il y a la familiarité aussi en termes de langue, français, par exemple, italienne.
Voilà, mais donc c'est un exemple de—
Le choix d'être— ben, en tant qu'immigrant, on a plusieurs choix, à s'acculturer. Donc est-ce qu'on garde notre propre culture, pardon, ou non ?
Est-ce qu'on apprend ou est-ce qu'on essaye d'appliquer la culture de la société d'où on vient, pardon, d'où on arrive, oui ou non ?
Et donc la combinaison entre ces deux dimensions peut faire que, par exemple, quelqu'un a fait le choix de
de s'assimiler et de dire : « Je laisse tomber mon héritage italien dans ce cas et je deviens 100 % belge », si c'est quelque chose ou non, une identité belge qui a été pris.
Il y a des personnes qui souhaitent intégrer les deux, l'origine versus la nouvelle culture. Il y a des personnes qui laissent tomber les deux, qui se marginalisent.
Ou il y a des personnes qui se séparent et qui ne veulent rien à faire avec la culture belge, mais qui restent ou qui souhaitent de garder leur culture d'origine, par exemple italienne.
Mh. Voilà, donc on a digressé là sur le sujet des gens—
Pardon.
Non, mais c'est normal. C'est, on fait beaucoup ça dans ce podcast. Donc c'est les personnes donc issues de l'immigration qui votent pour l'extrême anti-immigration.
Mais donc je reviens sur toi.
Mh.
Et tes— comment est-ce que tu gères tes biais, tes positions politiques, tes convictions politiques ? Et comment est-ce que tu fais en sorte que ton travail reste neutre ?
Est-ce que c'est possible que ton travail reste neutre ? Ou est-ce qu'il est obligatoirement entaché ou il est obligatoirement impacté par toi, qui tu es, tes positions, tes idées ?
Je pense que c'est vrai que, ben, le travail en soi reste neutre, mais les idées et aussi les discussions que j'ai avec mes collègues, etc., sont souvent inspirées par ce qui se passe dans la société.
Donc—
Votre lecture de ce qui se passe dans la société.
Oui, tout à fait. Oui. Et en plus, cette
tour d'ivoire dans laquelle on parle,
je trouve que c'est vraiment à nous maintenant, parce qu'on reçoit beaucoup d'argent de la société, des citoyens belges, de refaire l'effort, de faire, par exemple, faire des podcasts comme ça et,
de parler de ce qu'on a appris de notre étude.
Donc c'est vraiment— on peut s'inspirer, mais on peut aussi informer le débat politique ou juste faire que les gens soient conscients de leurs biais.
Moi aussi, je suis conscient que la façon dans laquelle je choisis mes questions de recherche peut être inspirée par n'importe quelle valeur que j'ai.
Donc c'est une balance très très délicate, qui— oui. On dit souvent que
le monde académique n'est pas représentatif de, disons, de l'électorat, parce qu'ils ont proportionnellement plus de personnes à gauche qu'à droite ou que dans le reste de la société.
C'est quelque chose que, à nouveau, qu'on doit être très très conscient sur cela. Parce que je— même dans le monde académique,
ça peut arriver qu'il y a certaines opinions qui ne sont pas trop bienvenues et qui sont peut-être ignorées, même si ces personnes-là qui ont choisi leurs propres questions, qui montrent leurs propres résultats, doivent être
inclus dans le débat, je trouve, et qu'on doit écouter, on doit lire les papiers que souvent, on n'aime pas lire.
Pour donner l'exemple, j'ai parlé de Bowling Alone. C'est Robert Putnam, le politicologue qui a écrit ça, qui a eu une influence énorme, aussi dans la société américaine dans ce cas.
Donc, il a été invité par Barack Obama aussi pour parler de ses études parce qu'en 2007, il a publié un papier, E pluribus unum,
qui a montré que dans des contextes plus diversifiés, il y a moins— il y a beaucoup de résultats négatifs, il y a presque que des résultats négatifs.
Il a parlé de moins de confiance, moins de solidarité, moins de bénévolat, plus de préjugés, plus de négativité.
Et quand on parle de moins de confiance, il a montré que c'était en général, que c'était envers, par exemple, des personnes immigrées, mais aussi ce qu'on appelle confiance dans notre endogroupe, donc la confiance dans
des personnes qui sont comme nous.
Et ça, c'était, ben un papier que je trouve qui a eu un rôle dans la psychologie politique, par exemple, et surtout dans mon domaine de recherche, les relations intergroupes,
qui a eu une telle influence, mais c'était nécessaire de montrer ces résultats, pour stimuler un débat.
Et que sept ans après cette publication, il y avait cent papiers qui ont testé cette hypothèse dans d'autres pays, par exemple aux Pays-Bas, moins en Belgique, ou en Allemagne, mais aussi aux États-Unis.
Et on a trouvé qu'il y avait une diversité dans les résultats sur la question de diversité. Il y avait des papiers qui ont montré une association comme Putnam, qui montre qu'il y a beaucoup de, disons,
d'attitudes négatives sur la diversité.
Il y a d'autres qui ont montré que c'était lié avec des choses positives, par exemple plus de contacts intergroupes, etc.
Moi, j'ai souvent trouvé des, disons, des résultats zéro, que ça n'a— quand on regarde au niveau sociétal, qu'il y a pas d'effet. Et là,
c'est là où j'ai trouvé qu'il faut aussi inclure le niveau individuel.
Parce que le fait qu'on trouve que la diversité n'était pas liée, par exemple, à la confiance, c'est parce que pour certaines personnes, c'était lié avec plus de confiance et pour d'autres, c'était lié avec moins de confiance.
Et là, on trouve cette dynamique, cette polarisation qui n'est peut-être pas visible encore au niveau sociétal, mais qui, ben, qu'on peut voir aussi dans nos données.
Et je pense que la solution, entre guillemets, est pareille que pour la société ou le débat politique au niveau des citoyens et citoyennes.
Je trouve que le moment qu'on ignore une certaine partie des publications, qu'on veut pas parler avec un ou une collègue qui a des valeurs différentes, c'est là où on oublie qu'on est chercheur académique et que—
Si on freine sa curiosité, on n'est pas un très bon chercheur.
Oui.
Oui. Mais donc c'est intéressant parce que tu donnais le constat donc de ce papier de recherche, donc c'est dans les années nonante alors, c'est ça ou ?
2007.
2007, oh pardon.
Le grand papier, oui.
C'est ça. Et donc tu disais, enfin le papier qui disait, dans un contexte avec la diversité, plus de méfiance par rapport aux étrangers.
Du coup, voilà, l'exogroupe, c'est ça ?
Oui.
Et aussi par rapport à l'endogroupe.
Ben oui. Pardon.
C'est un exemple où je me dis : un chercheur pourrait regarder ça et se dire : la présence de l'exogroupe, la présence des immigrés est un problème—
Oui.
Puisqu'on a moins confiance entre nous.
Mmm-hmm.
Et donc c'est une lecture biaisée, puisqu'un autre chercheur aurait dit : « Mais non, pas du tout, c'est pas du tout comme ça.
» Et donc un chercheur est difficilement neutre alors dans un exemple comme celui-là.
Ben, il y a cette question de recherche, il y a l'interprétation des résultats. Et là, je trouve que,
ben si on trouve cette association négative, disons, si on trouve que la diversité est liée avec des problèmes, là, il faut juste rapporter ce qui en est.
Et on peut réfléchir, comme personne, plutôt que comme chercheur, chercheuse, que comment résoudre ce problème-là.
Mais le fait de ne pas parler— Ben, Robert Putnam avait l'option de ne pas publier ce qu'il a trouvé. Et il a publié, il a stimulé un débat énorme.
Par exemple, toi, tu as vu ce papier et tu t'es dit : je vais aussi m'intéresser alors au niveau individuel parce que ça, ça doit expliquer, voilà.
Quelqu'un d'autre aurait peut-être regardé les résultats et ne se serait pas intéressé au niveau individuel et il aurait juste publié les premières observations au niveau sociétal.
Oui.
Et c'est un choix.
Ah oui, oui.
Un choix qui est impacté par des biais, par des positions, par une certaine lecture.
Ouais.
Et donc, je—
Oui, pour—
Tu vois que j'ai du mal avec cette notion de « les chercheurs sont neutres », hein.
Ah oui, oui, oui. Mais moi aussi.
Ça va alors.
Ouais. Non non, mais par exemple, le fait que j'ai choisi d'inclure
le niveau individuel, c'était plutôt parce que j'étais formé par mes profs, par exemple,
dans— au niveau politique, qui regardent souvent les idéologies, par exemple, comme prédicteur de attitudes politiques ou envers la migration, etc.
D'autres chercheurs qui... Leur propre opinion, je connais pas nécessairement, mais qui, par exemple, souvent, ont regardé les idées, les théories de menace, etc.
On inclut ce variable-là et on trouvait que c'est vrai que la diversité peut augmenter la menace, en même temps que le contact et qu'il y a ces deux chemins.
Une, c'est positive, entre guillemets, que la diversité stimule le contact qui réduit les préjugés ou qui augmente la tolérance.
Et le chemin négatif, comment dire, c'est que
la diversité peut stimuler ou peut augmenter les sentiments de menace qui se traduisent au niveau attitude comme plus de préjugés, moins de tolérance ou au niveau politique comme plus de votes pour des extrêmes.
Sentiment d'insécurité ou ce genre de choses.
Oui. Ou de
de sentiment que, bah de nostalgie de temps en temps, que à l'époque, c'était mieux ou de
plutôt compétitivité avec : ah oui, maintenant, on est ici avec plus de personnes ou si— dans une proportion que je ne connais pas ou qui est pas comme nous
et on doit battre pour les mêmes jobs.
On va perdre notre propre culture, nos coutumes qui étaient si précieux, etc etc. Donc tous ces facteurs peuvent jouer un rôle aussi.
Oui. Le fait qu'il y a cette présence de diversité ou de proportions de personnes issues de la migration peut inciter beaucoup de processus.
Et je pense que même aujourd'hui, on n'a pas trouvé chaque variable qui est liée avec la diversité. C'est pour ça que je veux encore plus me focaliser sur ça ou comme on vient de parler des prédicteurs de cynisme.
Je pense qu'il y a des études, mais pas encore beaucoup. Donc c'est un domaine qui, de n'importe quelle
classe ou famille idéologique ou politique qu'on vient, que ça vaut la peine de quand même examiner des trucs qui sont liés avec le cynisme ou les attitudes politiques, ouais.
Oui oui oui. On va bientôt terminer. On arrive au bout des 70 minutes. J'avais une question que j'avais oubliée de poser tout à l'heure vis-à-vis de— tu disais,
des expériences positives avec, par exemple, des personnes issues de l'immigration,
vont diminuer le cynisme et vont
diminuer la polarisation, etc.
Est-ce qu'on peut observer aussi l'inverse ? Personne qui a une expérience négative—
Oui.
...avec une personne issue de l'immigration—
Ouais.
...et qui du coup va se renfermer sur l'idée que... Voilà, mais donc plus de contacts avec l'exogroupe, c'est pas forcément positif. Ça peut—
Oui.
Ça peut donner des expériences négatives aussi.
Oui. Donc, il y a plusieurs façons de mesurer ce contact-là.
Mh.
Et à l'époque, c'était juste fréquence. Et le plus de contacts était lié avec moins de préjugés, moins de biais, etc.
Donc c'était un résultat, bah peut-être normal quoi. Puis, on a fait la différence entre type de contact et ça peut être négatif, ça peut être positif.
Là et maintenant, c'est un débat encore dans la littérature, mais les premiers papiers qui ont sortis montrent que, ou montraient
que des contacts négatifs, même si c'est moins fréquent, ont une influence beaucoup plus large que des contacts positifs.
Mh.
Donc la fortitude ou la magnitude d'une expérience négative peut même détruire sept expériences positives.
Donc c'est vraiment—
Quand tu parles d'expérience, c'est obligatoirement contact face à face ou bien est-ce que ça peut être— voilà, par exemple, cette semaine, on a eu
il y en a— dans l'actualité, il y a eu ce fait qu'à Anvers, y a des jeunes qui ont volé une ambulance. Et donc—
Ouais.
J'en parle parce que Bart De Wever a réagi en disant : « Ah, c'est toujours le même profil. On n'est pas étonné quand on les a vus.
» Bon, il dit pas explicitement que c'est des Maghrébins, mais en fait, c'est ça qu'il veut dire. Et donc, est-ce que ça compte comme expérience de contact négatif avec l'exogroupe ?
Oui. Donc quand on parle des contacts, ça peut être direct, comme nous avons aujourd'hui, mais ça peut être indirect.
Et donc là, il y a plusieurs facteurs. Il y a les médias qui peuvent, et dans les médias, pour être honnête, il y a aussi ce biais de négativité.
Un événement négatif est plus newsworthy, donc il y a plus de—
Négativité, ouais.
Oui. En même temps, on a ce qu'on appelle, bah la connaissance d'un membre d'un endogroupe qui a des expériences positives ou négatives avec l'exogroupe.
Donc moi, maintenant, je connais beaucoup de francophones belges en tant que néerlandophone belge parce que je travaille à Bruxelles.
J'habite près de Gand où il y a, bah pas beaucoup de diversité en termes de langue, pardon. Et donc pour mes amis flamands,
eux, ils me connaissent et je— ils savent que j'ai des expériences, et je dis honnêtement, ils sont beaucoup positifs, mais aussi de temps en temps négatifs.
Et donc, si je leur en parle, ça peut changer leurs opinions. Et donc c'est ça qui est très intéressant, même si ces effets sont moins prononcés.
Forcément, ouais.
Et l'intimité du contact est aussi très très important. Les interventions qui marchent le plus pour réduire les préjugés sont, quand on arrive à l'université, on a un roommate qui vient d'un autre groupe.
Parce que là, souvent, on devient des amis, on a des liens plus intimes que si on est dans la boulangerie et on achète un croissant.
Il y a aussi beaucoup d'expériences neutres qui n'ont aucune intensité, etc. Et donc ça peut changer, mais ça va pas changer beaucoup.
Oui. Le fait que traverser la taalgrens, la frontière linguistique, soit plus compliqué que si on parlait tous la même langue fait qu'il y a moins de contacts, donc moins d'expériences positives, plus de,
d'histoires, voilà, négatives dans les médias, par exemple.
Mh.
Donc c'est un facteur qui doit aussi un petit peu accélérer le cynisme et la polarisation, est-ce que—
Oui, oui, quand on parle des groupes linguistiques, mais ça, c'est historiquement, c'est normal que notre pays est divisé,
dans des régions qui sont dominées par une certaine, des deux langues ou des trois langues, il faut dire.
Mais oui, c'est là où le— à cause de ce— ou grâce à cette ségrégation, on a des mesures, par exemple, par les médias ou par les contacts indirects qui peuvent jouer un grand rôle.
Parce que c'est normal que toi, tu ne vas pas à Anvers chaque semaine pour parler avec des personnes. C'est, oui.
Non, c'est sûr. Mais même en Wallonie, je vais pas souvent. Donc c'est, c'est...
Oui, oui. Ça, j'ai appris, après mes trois ans ici, que—
Les Bruxellois ne sortent pas de Bruxelles ?
Pardon— Non, non. Non. Que dans les têtes de beaucoup de personnes néerlandophones belges—
Bruxelles et Wallonie, c'est la même chose.
Ce sont des francophones belges. Ce sont des Wallons, mais même si—
Ouais, ouais, faut— attention.
Donc, il faut faire attention avec l'identification de chacun et chacune.
Non, c'est clair.
Et c'est, oui, ça, j'ai appris ici. C'est très enrichissant aussi pour moi, pour voir cette dynamique-là.
Et je suis à chaque fois un petit peu trigger quand quelqu'un parle de la Belgique à l'étranger et dit : « Oui, il y a la Flandre et la Wallonie. »
Il faut dire Bruxelles aussi. Enfin, voilà. Donc ça, c'est une histoire de Belgique. Une autre question que j'avais,
oubliée de poser, c'était : est-ce qu'il y a une vérité dans l'idée de dire que les groupes, en fonction de l'âge, ont des positionnements politiques différents ?
Est-ce que c'est vrai de dire que quand on est plus jeune, on est plus à gauche, quand on est plus vieux, on est plus à droite ?
Oui, mais c'est pas le facteur le plus important. Mais oui.
OK.
On trouve une corrélation, âge et conservatisme, âge et support pour des partis aussi conservatrices, etc., conservateurs. Oui, tout à fait.
Est-ce que c'est lié au cynisme ou pas directement ?
Si. Oui. Mais donc, quand on parle des facteurs démographiques, aux États-Unis, à nouveau, on parlait des angry white men,
qui supportent Trump ou n'importe, mais on retrouve ça en Belgique ou dans des études où on prend en compte le genre, l'âge, etc.
Éducation, revenu ou,
etc., jouent un rôle. Mais quand on introduit, par exemple, les facteurs idéologiques, le cynisme, le,
des attitudes envers des propres thèmes qui sont uniques ou qui sont des motivateurs, par exemple, immigration, etc.,
on voit que le rôle des—
De l'âge—
Oui, ça diminue, ça devient—
Mais ce que je veux dire, c'est : est-ce que plus on est vieux, plus on est cynique ou pas, ou pas forcément ? Oui ?
Oui, mais oui. Mais c'est pas que c'est un sur un. C'est pas que celui, quelqu'un qui a cinquante ans doit être plus cynique que quelqu'un qui a trente ans.
C'est une tendance, une moyenne. Oui, oui.
Donc, tu parlais des angry white men aux États-Unis. Un truc qui était, donc tout le monde a— un exemple que tout le monde reprend régulièrement, c'est la quote de Hillary Clinton,
où elle avait parlé de ce, donc ces gens-là, cet électorat-là, en disant les deplorables.
Oui.
En français, on dirait les déplorables. Je sais pas si ça marche très bien, mais...
Oui, j'ai vu le commentaire qui s'appelait les déplorables.
Oh, OK, bah voilà. Et, enfin, vous voyez, en français, on dirait peut-être même des... Oui, des gen— Non, ce serait pas des déchets, mais c'est un peu l'idée de dire, c'est pathétique quoi.
C'est des gens pathétiques quoi. Bon, c'est un peu ça l'idée. Et donc qui alors renforce peut-être ce genre de commentaires, renforce la polarisation et le fait de dire : « Il y a eux et il y a nous et on n'est pas ensemble. »
Peut-être on a dû commencer avec cet exemple. Parce que est-ce que ça, c'est la solution ? Donc on a ce schisme dans la société, on a un groupe où il y a tendance qu'une certaine partie de la population
n'est pas d'accord et veut un changement.
Et donc en stigmatisant ce groupe, parce que c'est vraiment un label, une catégorisation très très forte, très très négativement, ben négative.
Est-ce que ça, c'est la solution ? Est-ce qu'on doit essayer quand même d'avoir un discours plus inclusif qui reconnaît qu'il y a des soucis parmi cette population ?
Ce qu'on observe, c'est que ce genre de discours, ce genre de stigmatisation, accentue le sentiment anti-élites, et donc la colère. Et donc,
je— c'est mon impression, c'est ma compréhension qu'une large partie des gens qui votent encore Trump,
il y a un très très fort, très fort sentiment anti-establishment, anti-élites, les élites de New York, de Wall Street, de Washington, de Californie et tout ça.
Et donc justement, je parle de ça parce que cette semaine, il y a eu le mémorial du 11 septembre aux États-Unis, donc c'était il y a deux jours, la date où on enregistre ce podcast.
Ouais.
Et Trump, non, non, pas Trump, Biden, est allé visiter, je ne sais pas exactement où c'était, dans le Midwest, je présume, une caserne de pompiers.
Et il tombe, on— c'est filmé hein, sur plein de gens avec des casquettes Trump, des enfants qui étaient là, avec pl— j'imagine qu'ils ont été habillés par leurs parents, avec plein de t-shirts avec Donald Trump en très grand et tout ça.
Et Biden a, bon, il a fait quelques blagues au sujet, à ce sujet-là, mais,
mais globalement, il a été cool. Et il y a même cette image de lui qui, c'est presque choquant, mais il met la casquette du pompier, qui est une casquette Trump.
Ouais.
Voilà. Bon, là, on est à l'opposé de—
De la quote avec les deplorables de Hillary Clinton. Et effectivement, ce qu'on observe dans la vidéo, c'est que les gens ont l'air un peu plus friendly, un peu plus amicaux entre eux que si,
s'il est arrivé là en les insultant,
c'est déjà très différent.
Donc c'est un exemple qui, je pense, illustre pas mal ton propos.
Ben, il n'a rien à perdre, bien sûr, Biden.
Non, oui.
Mais quand même.
Ah, c'est vrai, oui, c'est vrai que—
Après avoir été élu, élu pardon, il a eu ce message que je suis le président de tous les Américains, toutes les Américaines, etc.
Donc il a quand même essayé d'être plus inclusif ou en incluant. Parce que oui, c'est vraiment, on en parlait, je pense la raison de, que la plupart des études est fait
aux États-Unis, c'est que c'est un contexte simple et c'est anglophone.
Et donc le monde académique, malheureusement, reste encore très très anglophone.
Oui. Le,
un exemple de Biden qui était donc président de tous les Américains, c'est qu'il était tout à fait transparent par rapport au fait que, par exemple, il considère que Mitch McConnell, qui est un,
une figure importante au, dans la House of Representatives, la Chambre des représentants aux États-Unis, il disait : « Bah oui, c'est mon ami, voilà, y a pas de souci. »
Ouais.
Donc c'est, il a jamais été très très polarisé, polarisant lui-même.
Il a toujours été, mais c'est peut-être aussi parce qu'il est vieux. Peut-être aussi un facteur qui fait qu'il vient d'une époque où on était moins polarisés.
Ouais, oui, peut-être, oui, oui.
Voilà, donc on a parlé de beaucoup de choses. Merci beaucoup pour cet entretien. Est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose que tu voudrais rajouter ?
Parce qu'on a traversé pas mal de sujets.
Oui, c'est vrai. Bah j'ai rien à ajouter, sauf que la dernière chose de laquelle tu parles m'a inspiré parce que j'ai lu un article sur, c'était Tobback et Dehaene, donc deux politiciens anciens, des deux familles.
On a parlé des familles politiques très très séparées qui apparemment étaient très très amicales.
OK.
Et donc,
il y avait sans doute des coalitions et des débats sur la coalition à l'époque qui étaient très très difficiles entre plusieurs partis,
belges, mais cette amitié personnelle a quand même aidé un petit peu des discussions denses.
Et donc, je me demande si c'est ça, c'est pas ça qui manque encore.
Est-ce que les politiciens sont amis entre eux encore aujourd'hui ? Bon, il y a un exemple de quelqu'un qui est ami avec personne, ce serait Georges-Louis Bouchez.
Parce que tu, ouais, il est fâché avec Bart De Wever, il est fâché avec Conner Rousseau. Voilà, c'était, en tout cas, c'est ce qui revient régulièrement.
Oui.
Mais je, c'est vrai que je n'ai pas vraiment d'idée d'amitié—
Oui, Conner Rousseau et Bart De Wever, on appelle ça le, la, le bromance un petit peu. Mais non, mais un exemple qui vient dans ma tête maintenant, c'est que, donc,
avant les élections qu'on a eues, c'était Melissa Depraetere-De Vreught, la présidente, qui a,
apparemment, dans un débat, dit : « Avant de parler avec Raoul Hedebouw des sujets politiques, je veux poser la question si tout va bien avec toi parce que j'ai entendu que t'as perdu ton père. »
Mh.
Et donc là, c'est vraiment humaniser l'autre—
C'est très calculé, mais oui.
Oui, ça peut être, oui, oui, tout à fait. Mais quand même, oui, si c'est honnête, si c'est genuine, ça peut, ben, pave the way pour une discussion moins polarisée, etc.
Bon, et l'autre exemple qui vient, c'est, je pense qu'y a quand même des atomes crochus entre les gens des Engagés et les gens du MR.
On sent qu'ils sont, qu'ils s'entendent assez bien.
Oui.
L'exemple qui moi me marque et que je reprends tout le temps quand on fait les comparaisons avec les États-Unis, avec la France, etc.
Mais c'était il y a déjà plus de dix ans. C'était au moment où il y avait les élections avec des politiciens qui ont disparu depuis, qui sont Joëlle Milquet, mevrouw Ney et Didier Reynders.
C'était sur un plateau de RTL. Et à la fin, le journaliste sur le plateau dit à Didier Reynders : « Voilà, on va bientôt se quitter.
Si vous deviez expliquer aux téléspectateurs pourquoi il ne faut surtout pas voter, qu'est-ce qui est, en quoi est-ce que Joëlle Milquet est vraiment pas bien ? »
Oui.
Pourquoi, voilà, tout ça. Je sais plus exactement comment il l'a dit, mais, et à ce moment-là, Didier Reynders dit : « Mais non, je vais pas faire ça, je vais l'embrasser, c'est mon ami.
» Et puis il traverse le plateau, il fait un bisou et puis l'émission s'arrête. Et ça, c'est inimaginable, par exemple en France ou aux États-Unis, etc. Donc—
Ouais.
Mais c'est vrai que c'est moins, c'est moins le cas aujourd'hui que, je pense, il y a dix, quinze ans.
Je pense que ça, ça a évolué à ce niveau-là.
Ouais.
Très bien. Les choses ont évolué. On verra comment les choses continuent à progresser. Merci beaucoup.
Réunion dans dix ans.
Oui, c'est ça. On va débriefer dans dix ans. Merci beaucoup pour ces Septante Minutes. Jasper.
Avec plaisir.
Et à très bientôt. Un grand merci à Jasper et aussi à Olivier Klein, le codirecteur du SESCoop, qui est donc le Center for Social and Cultural Psychology de l'ULB.
C'est en anglais. C'est pour ça que j'arrivais pas à retomber dessus pendant l'interview. Voilà, en ma défense. Si la psychologie sociale vous intéresse, ben le SESCoop a aussi son propre podcast, Mille grammes de savoir.
Je vous mets le lien en description. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à Septante Minutes Avec sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée et sur YouTube aussi, puisque du coup, comme je vous le disais,
à partir de maintenant, les interviews sont disponibles intégralement en vidéo.
J'espère que ça va pouvoir se maintenir dans le temps. J'espère que toutes les interviews vont pouvoir être enregistrées en vidéo.
Voilà, c'est— Je vais faire de mon mieux. Suivez-moi sur Instagram et sur TikTok également et pensez à laisser une review cinq étoiles, évidemment, sur votre plateforme préférée.
On se retrouve dans deux semaines avec Marie Pelletier. À très bientôt.